[Music]
this talk is gonna cover kind of a broad
range of themes it's gonna be a little
circuitous it's gonna go through a
couple of tunnels to get to a general
overview of what we're trying to
accomplish with the observatory Amir
overall I would say you know there gonna
be a lot of observability components a
lot of data components there will be ml
as well but it all kind of fits together
as a data product all right so table of
contents are a little bit of intro some
foundations and motivations for the
product putting some pieces together
there'll be a little bit of tracing a
single event through the entire pipeline
a little bit of conversation around the
future and then if you guys have any
questions and answers I'm happy to
converse all right so do is a global
cloud hosting provider we've been around
since well I don't have the date on here
2012 we have 12 data centers worldwide
and we build products that help
engineering teams build deploy and scale
cloud applications you may be familiar
with droplet that's our compute our VM
solution we have block storage object
storage and myriad other products cool
so I'm not gonna talk so much about
myself the only thing I'll throw out is
if anyone can figure out my past
recorded music output you get bonus
points and you can use my Twitter handle
for that which I'm not publicizing here
absorb bility applications in in for
analytics those are my team's we are
kind of like a hybrid of software
engineers data engineers data analysts
and we we sit atop analytics
infrastructure basically that includes
things like Mesa sauce Kafka hive Hadoop
presto and looker among other
applications all right so what's the Oh
a mission to simplify an optimized
internal consumption of data from
distributed systems to reduce incident
MTD D and M TDR that's mean time to
detection and resolution through
some applications to help define
maintain and broadcast source of truth
performance and reliability data to the
rest of the org all right what's the ia
mission oh look there's some similar
stuff right so to generate insights
through data for the infrastructure and
wider organizations to build an overt
and oversee a centralized data platform
and also to help define maintain and
broadcast source of truth data to the
rest of the org so a little bit more
general around the data and those are
the previous bullet points so how can we
actually achieve these things let's
build the observatory all right so some
foundations and motivations all right
the what so it's in sort of an
oversimplified perspective it's a
centralized application to help reduce
MT D D and M TDR and in this case it's
the cost and impact of incidence so
improving the reliability of our overall
cloud through curated data here are some
of the motivating questions I want to
know the current health of the cloud I
want to see the live health and
historical performance of all services
that relate to drop the creation so this
is just an example right someone comes
in wants to understand how droplet
creation is performing if it's reliable
how customers are seeing things so you
want to see the live version and the
historical view there all right so
there's currently an outage I wonder if
any outages like this one have occurred
before and if so how they were fixed so
using past data to inform how to triage
things and solve current issues in the
club I want to understand the
reliability of any and all customer
facing products over time so not
necessarily as narrow towards droplet
creates towards that function but really
the breadth of our product suite
anything that can impact a customer and
thus you know our revenue all right and
more internal facing so how much of our
team's weekly monthly annual error
budget have we depleted as of today
finally a little bit more sort sort of
towards the future literally I want to
know if there any warning signs about
the current performance that will lead
to degradation of my services in the
near future
so being able to predict service
failures is pretty critical as we're
building out our reliability suite
okay back to what so how can we start
building to answer these questions so
we'll talk a little bit about some some
foundations here SLN service catalog and
observability platforms right in
all right service level management so
this is basically an umbrella that
covers SLA SSL OHS and SSL eyes some of
you may be familiar with those I don't
know if you're familiar with all three
but SLA is your traditional agreement
with consequences so typically what your
customers will see as your public facing
expected contract of reliability whether
that's an external or internal customer
it applies to both an objective or goal
is the SLO so what each team who owns a
service expects or hopes for that
service to perform at in terms of a
level and then your SLI is the actual
indicator or metric that reveals whether
or not you're actually meeting that s
alone cool so this slide is really to
show you kind of the overall perspective
right so SLA s are consumed by your
stakeholders they're the ones who see
what your you're promising your SLO and
wrestle eyes or you define those
internally and in terms of temporal
prioritization right you want to do your
s lows and SL eyes first and then do
your SL is you don't want to publicize
anything that you haven't validated
right so who owns those SLO is SL eyes
the service owner teams so one key point
here as the observability group we try
to abstain from any type of ownership
conversations with teams we are really
just the vessel the conduit the
objective method by which we can surface
the information and where are these s
flows and SL has defined so that's
that's kind of a hint at a catalogue of
services right so a service catalog is a
pretty generic term some of you may have
those in your organization's it's a
great way to basically centralize and
standardize information it's a central
authority for distributed micro services
in our case so one of the main
requirements here is that a service must
have a complete service
a log entry to be allowed to deploy to
production this is something we're
testing out right now it's a little
bumpy because you know cultural paradigm
shifts here in terms of you know
accountability towards towards
restrictions and constraints that's
never fun for anyone let's define what
that complete entry is before you say oh
that's too much to ask of someone all
right so here's just an example some of
the details have been obfuscated for you
know safety reasons but you want to have
your contact information your severity
level you can you can read through the
slide but basically couple things I want
to identify here with my pointer let's
see there we go cool so you have your
SLI defined here it's an explicit query
in this case in Prometheus and your SLO
is that nice float right there you know
there's there's links to like the github
repo and your your JIRA ticket projects
and all that kind of fun stuff the other
thing here dependencies it's an array of
ID's these are fabricated IDs but the
notion is that you are identifying the
dependencies that your service has on
other services so things that your
service depends on which is pretty
important done one all right and then
lastly in terms of the foundations I
want to cover organizationally in
observability we have a platforms group
in an applications group I'm the ladder
in the former we have a bunch of folks
who support centralized systems such as
our centralized metrics which are
through Prometheus Pandora is our
internal interpretation slash
administrative portal for handling all
the Promethea Prometheus's and if you're
not familiar with it just a quick slide
it has a lot it's very easy to implement
and deploy at scale it's very flexible
in terms of how you generate these time
series metrics you can have counters
gauges and what's great is you can
generate you can fabricate recording
rules which from the previous slide in
the Service Catalog umut it's it's
basically a recording rule SLI so you're
creating a query it generates the data
it exports that as time series right so
this is just a configuration file
pandora is the centralized authority
here
it's the amalgamation of all these
different Prometheus
servers that are distributed globally
and it's simple ammo to configure it the
initial the MVP from a couple years ago
that we were doing in terms of
centralizing data in Pandora and pulling
it into our processing it was leveraging
a lot of Python and SPARC and using a
pull mechanism and ultimately this
really didn't scale very well so we
generated a new remote right or we we
injected the Pandora repo with some
remote and bright capabilities which
allow us to earmark whitelist certain
metrics that then are pushed into our
systems which is a lot better so that's
the configuration there right one little
addendum and Polyjuice is something that
another member of the observability team
wrote to effectively coerce centralized
logs in syslog format into Prometheus
metrics which is great because that
allows everyone who's basically
predicating their met their data their
telemetry on logging to also participate
with our systems and metric format like
this so here this example is a nice
latency histogram which is great for
what we want to do right so back to
those you've seen all these bullet
points before my point here is that it
is a data product we want to answer all
of these stakeholder questions and there
are multiple customer personas and thus
we kind of have to start designing this
as a product from a product manager
perspective which is really interesting
problem statement for us as engineers -
all right so here's some diagrams coming
up yeah so this is currently you know
I'll go through some of this the parts
that matter that are pertinent to this
conversation but right here you can
think of this is Service Catalog going
into Pandora
remote writing into our system starting
the ingest er this is basically you know
the entirety of this lovely Observatory
insisting we are leveraging a
centralized kafka bus and using it kind
of creatively kind of by necessity to
start processing doing a lot of sort of
streaming
but I don't want to stay on the sled
right okay that was supposed to come in
earlier but I started talking too much
but right so here I'm highlighting a
couple things with the grey and with the
red the red side here is primarily gonna
be like that's what the customer is
going to experience these are these are
components that I want to highlight
later on and the gray is going to be a
data flow that we're gonna follow right
now right so back to the the beginning
of the flow so we start in Pandora Wii
Remote right in it leverages all the SLO
and s lies that are already codified
within the Service Catalog it comes into
the in gesture here's how we're defining
those recording rules in Pandora this is
the structure of the data as it comes in
and you can see at the very bottom this
is what it looks like on the Prometheus
API or on the UI and above it is how it
looks in the in gesture so you know this
is this is relatively straightforward
data it's coming through in time service
format and now we're into Kafka and we
are digesting this so we're effectively
normalizing the data a little bit more
we are injecting it with a couple bits
of metadata and processing it in a way
that allows us down straight this will
make sense subsequently right here so
this allows us right now to basically
process that data and write it with
timestamp information and the payload
down into Hadoop re DW which then allows
us to store things historically which is
critical for you know when we're moving
forward into the sort of product
features that they'll talk about okay
and the other started side of this so
real quick going back here it's in
Hadoop this is just a raw row from SPARC
it's in a park a file the key point here
is you have a lot of stakeholders who
are curious about this data but aren't
necessarily equipped with the skills to
parse raw park' files so we're coming in
and trying to accommodate you know
presto sequel is what we've deployed
across the organization overall so we
want to make sure that it's reachable
thus
so we we wrote something we called the
trim Reaper which basically is an auto
partitioner in hive and exposes the data
nicely for everyone and there you go so
basically this is exposed to anyone with
a with the proper presto connection at
the org so backtracking a little bit in
fact I'm gonna backtrack a lot real
quick just to give right so I was just
talking about this up here this is where
we're going into Hadoop with the trim
Reaper and now you have this nice
historical warehouse that's happening
and being populated and then we'll talk
about how to extract it later but I also
want to say that in parallel we're
writing into a real-time front-end API
and then the front-end itself so let's
look at those real quick right back here
oh sorry yep so this is the front-end
API what we're doing here which is
really interesting is we're taking
multiple events and we're windowing them
and we're providing basically a
normalization a time normalization
around the data and so you can see that
the start and end time stamps here are
you know ten minute boxes and we have 20
of the observations these are coming
from multiple Pandora servers and we're
effectively normalizing them we're
averaging them out it is definitely sort
of it's it's not as absolutely granular
but ultimately what it's going to be
used for is it's totally sufficient
which is servicing information here in
real time on the UI that basically
surfaces data that if you have anything
that's not meeting its SLO it comes out
as an event and unhealthy events so
categorically all events on this live
pane of glass across the entire cloud
are going to be unhealthy things that
anyone at the organisation can come to
and see ok this is you know blowing up
or we're having some problems across you
know services A through F or whatever so
the great thing here is that you're able
to see not only what the SLO is but how
far below you are with the SLI itself
here this is a latency so the SLI is is
measuring much much higher than the the
200 millisecond SLO all right
cool so going back these are all the
questions we already talked about them
you know I'm teen x but it's all about
how we're designing this this complex
data product from that architectural
diagram to meet the needs of the
stakeholders in the organization right
so a little different view into the into
the structure we have what we just saw
in that little UIs snapshot was the live
pane of glass the ability to have SLO
and SLI historical data and aggregated
reporting there's the arrow budget API
an incident API and a degradation
prognostication API which you know we
might change the name of but alright so
I just want to associate those thought
bubbles those requests with these
components right so the current health
of the cloud is likely in the live pane
of glass the reliability of any and all
customer facing products over time
you'll see that in our SL n historical
and aggregated reporting SLM again I'm
just using as that proxy for really
anything that comes under that umbrella
our job that creates working great yes
back to the live in a glass have they
been working well now I need to look
historically and I should probably look
at era budget API to get a different
perspective on how everything is
performing all right and then the outage
and the incidence this is going to be
we'll talk a little bit more in depth
about this one but that's its own sort
of standalone mechanism and then
forecasting whether there will be
degradation in the future right so again
a little bit different on the
architecture a little bit more
simplified cleaner you have your uh
slows your SL eyes that array of service
dependencies there will be service
functions and tags so you can say okay
service X actually belongs to this set
of product functions so like a droplet
create for example all that metadata
will be part of the catalog annotations
that flows into Pandora it's tightly
coupled as we saw with Hadoop in this
case rtw and that flows up red is
real-time blue is batch purples and mix
that's the code alright alright so here
are some of the the the end results of
those components again we've seen this
before in the Y pane of glass so the
kind of historical aggregate report
it can be you know it can run the gamut
from say like here's a searchable table
of all these these data points you can
search for your product name it'll be
you know index with elasticsearch or
whatever you need to do to run your free
text analysis on your searching and it
allows you to see month-over-month
year-over-year ultimately this is just
an arbitrary snapshot here but era
budget api this is the algorithm if
you're familiar with era budgets it's
pretty straightforward you have this
many errors based on your SLO and its
relative to you know what how you'd
codify your SLO s-- right right so i
squeeze this all on on page so this is
the incident api is a little bit more
interesting this involves clustering the
mechanism here again is to answer has an
incident like this or similar to this
happen before so naturally that feeds
the idea of like a clustering algorithm
or a similarity matching algo and so the
notion is that in order there's an
incident it happens it's triggered that
could be you know someone on our
operational side says alright we've
started this incident it's at the
severity level and we are now you know
triaging it officially in this in this
slack channel what-have-you so we'll
have a web hook it triggers annotation
begins against all services so what that
means is there's a payload in the
metadata around the data flowing into
Hadoop and that allows us to inject say
like the the incident ticket or the you
know the basically some kind of
annotation that allows us to say like at
this point moving forward all of these
events all these services all these data
points on our system are potentially
related to this incident that's
occurring and I can allow for you know
simultaneous incidents if needed right
and so what we're also able to do is we
do have historically that buildup of all
the datasets over time that also may
have been part of previous incidents so
we have you know nice old time series to
run as training data as modeling and so
we end up you know building out the
matrices and comparing these to these
different sets of time series against
each other and you get you know the best
matches whether or not it's it's an
propria how much there is overlap
clearly we don't want to surface red
herrings all the time but if there's a
an appropriate thing then we will
surface that information up to the
operational agents and will suggest say
okay this incident happened previously
and here's how it was solve and perhaps
use that to reduce your you know time to
resolution right so ultimately what's
gonna happen and what's gonna help us is
there's sort of a manual feedback loop
as well that comes into play the
incidents over we lock the annotation so
it stops writing the incident ID to
these things
we then push into an incident metadata
DB some of the interesting information
that comes with it so that you know the
time range of triaging the teams that
were involved the potential services
that were identified as as pertinent to
the incident and so that is then used
alternately in the next incident right
and they and ultimate goal here is to
reduce MTD are okay right so forecasting
failures it's not dissimilar to the sort
of data modelling that we just talked
about ultimately we have time series of
every single service that's in our
system we have that historical data we
build those time series out we are able
to with dependencies and other perhaps
functional tags things that are allowing
us to group intelligently we can then
see okay if service a is has had a
problem historically then it has an
impact directly on service a and B on B
and C sorry and that o in real time
we're seeing a has a problem so we
should start alerting on B and C as well
and so it's basically var in the context
of stats non soccer but in in this
context it's it's a relatively
straightforward timeseriesforecasting
mechanism right so stepping through
again historical performance and
reliability metrics already exist right
we've already warehouse all the stuff
historically and we have dependencies
identified explicitly between services
which helps so we create vector
autoregressive models and then we batch
them and refreshed
so they're always being updated so
they're ready to forecast as needed
and then we enter what we call the
alerting protocol so currently this is
configured within Pandora within
Prometheus for alert manager but there
is a potential next up here to build out
a very explicit alerting mechanism for
this type of alerting so it's not
confused with some of the others that
are more generic that are built in by
other teams so this is more like the
observatory I'm specific alert right so
ultimately the goal is to provide
warnings and messaging before the
service drops to low before their
degradation cool so again the goal here
is to reduce the number of incidents
overall because ultimately we want to
make sure that teams are aware by by
being proactive on our side we can make
them aware of potential signals which is
great all right so real quick 20/20
vision adoption expansion and impact ok
so just just retracing steps a little
bit Service Catalog is gatekeeper one of
them the main goals here is to
standardize how the entire organization
defines their services whether that's
their s flows the rest lies the names of
their JIRA projects you know all that
stuff if you don't comply you don't you
can't deploy I thought that was an
interesting use of the English language
so I trademarked it unofficially but
alright bringing ml into the broader
data product toolkit and lexicon across
the organization so you know
traditionally I'm Alouette at an
operational I'd like do s and
infrastructure as a service place we
provide cloud infrastructure for for
users ml isn't necessarily the
motivation for building the observatory
emerging it because it's the right tool
for the job depending on what API were
building out and what the end goal is
and what we're trying to address for
customers so leveraging that as okay
here's the PSC we're using ml this is
how we're using it that we're not
necessarily saying like you need to be
data scientist or a machine learning
engineer or anything of that nature to
participate in this it's broadening the
appeal of the the efficacy
right and so as we're building out new
product SLA is across the board so you
know droplet block object etc we want to
have that obviously predicated on real
data we don't just want to fabricate it
out of thin air
so the observatory becomes the source of
truth for for those essays ultimately we
also want to build out telemetry to
understand who's using the observatory
and how they're using it basically
understanding you know what could be
more efficient how you know we can
iterate on our product design as well
and demarcating between staging and pre
prod environments and ensuring that
folks understand that reliability of
their associated services before they
deployed a production potentially caused
a mess expansion right our goal all
services i've SLO as an SLI is to find
no matter their proximity to customer so
you're gonna have you know dependencies
the underbelly is significant right so
you're gonna have so many things in the
micro service cloud that a customer will
never see nevertheless it needs to be
instrumented properly so we're getting
there were 90 something percent right
now which is great our budgets are
available ad hoc so anyone can come in
and look at the our budget API they can
search for a service a product any sort
of level tearing and they'll be able to
understand sort of how how much of an
objective era budget has been depleted
at a given time which is great for
managers and leadership to come in
alright and then this is a key to we've
only really talked about Prometheus as
the source data but we do have a lot of
other data points data formats
throughout the org right we have kafka
streams we have a bunch of relational
databases and no sequel and all that so
we need to be able to build out plugins
to the observatory on to the ingest or
in just a point so that we can leverage
and standardize the data flowing through
and again the production staging
dichotomy right we want to make sure
that things are properly measured in
stage and before deployed to production
we also want to integrate directly with
our deployment tracker which will allow
us to overlay deployments as you know
potential intervention analysis or what
have you in terms of the impact
an explicit time stamp deploy will have
on the reliability of the cloud right
impacts these are all kind of
overlapping just arbitrary terms right
fewer customer tickets and complaints
about reliability that's that's pretty
standard we want to reduce that teams
will iterate on their SL O's and work to
reduce outage counts and overall time
running degraded services again this is
you know pretty common sense teams don't
want to have crappy services but you
know this is a way for them to take
ownership over that and define their SL
O's and say look we are the ones who are
holding our own feet to the fire on this
right more mature Pratt pattern
recognition among micro service leads
among micro services leads to better
cross team developmental collaboration
so you have folks who are overseeing and
privy to how different parts of their
own pillars say the compute pillar for
example all those those parts are
performing and starting to recognize
again when one service goes down has an
impact on another service ultimately
that can only lead to better
conversations between teams and more
cohesive architecture and ultimately
right we want to reduce MTD are so
incidents are gonna happen what can we
do to actually help people fight those
incidents and solve the problems alright
that was under 30 any questions hey can
you talk about if you guys do any
automation on like the service yamo file
there's a lot of stuff like pedigree
things dependencies it's not just all
done by hand or like you have any ideas
of how you could automate that yep so
we're currently migrating everything out
of yeah Mille into a back end we have
tracing deployed we haven't necessarily
tested it all the way through to believe
in it fully but ostensibly all all
services have tracing has just as they
have logging and metrics it's part of
the o AR the operational acceptance
readiness process and so by leveraging
the data flowing through the tracing we
can basically infer all the dependencies
and generate those yeah one more
question I think you Alex for your talk
that was great maybe two questions so
the
first one is because you mentioned that
for example you observe and monitor how
droplet droplet is being created and the
question is the monitor your own
Observatory I mean how do you do that
and the second question is about data
retention I mean all your work is I
guess about real-time processing the
data and when you monitoring the
incidence and the question is how do you
storage all this data and what was the
retention yeah totally so the first
question I would say we would be
complete hypocrites if we didn't
instrument our own service and the SLO
is we're defining they're they're
multifaceted so we're looking at things
like attempts at hitting our historical
API UI different pages on the UI things
of that nature so that is all generated
we have an external Prometheus scraper
and that just exports into Pandora
naturally and so in terms of retention
we have a you know the luxury of being
an infrastructure organizations that we
do have relatively solid Headroom on our
on our warehouse store and so we
basically are able to push data into
Hadoop and we do have you know archival
mechanisms after a certain distance in
the past but we we have the ability to
aggregate those to the point where
they're still useful so we don't even
really have the cold storage up
[Music]